foreign
welcome back everybody we've been
following the investigation into Rex
heuerman the man suspected of killing
multiple women found on Long Island's
Gilgo Beach well this week it was
announced that another arrest has been
made but this time it's a law
enforcement official that's right James
Burke was the Suffolk County Police
Chief from 2012 to 2015 overseeing the
investigation into the Gilgo Beach case
11 bodies have been found along the Long
Island Coastline since 2010 and huerman
the Manhattan Architect by day an
alleged Predator by night was charged
with three of the murders this summer
well Burke was heavily criticized by
other law enforcement officials for his
handling of the case over a decade ago
they claimed he blocked the department
from cooperating with the FBI and
ultimately botched the investigation and
Burke's troubles really didn't stop
there because following Burke's
resignation Federal prosecutors charged
him with beating a handcuffed man and
covering up the attack that man was
suspected of stealing sex-related
material from Burke's department SUV
also arrested in connection to the
cover-up where the County's longtime
district attorney and ironically the
County's top corruption prosecutor Burke
served 40 months in federal prison and
was released in 2019. fast forward to
Tuesday when Burke was arrested again
but this time for allegedly attempting
to engage in sex acts with an undercover
park ranger current Suffolk County
Police Chief Rodney a Harrison said a
sting operation was carried out after
several complaints of solicitation at
the Vietnam Veterans Memorial Park on
Long Island during Burke's arrest
officials say he even tried to leverage
his former title as a way to get out of
it Burks charged with offering a sex act
public lewdness and decent exposure and
criminal solicitation and a Raymond day
has yet to be announced so Terry could
Burke's arrest compromise this entire
investigation I think so and even worse
than that I think it could compromise
the arrest of Rex Pilgrim because here
you have someone who is overseeing the
entire investigation and he's now been
charged with all of these crimes and the
sex crimes particularly if in fact it's
connected then maybe the you know
investigation was compromised maybe he
was covering up things because he didn't
want anything to lead back to him and
when I say he I mean Burke so I
definitely think that it's a big problem
they obviously are going to have to go
back and look at the evidence that has
been collected to make sure they have
the right evidence in fact some of that
in court could be all thrown out because
there could be some tainted evidence
there so I think this is a big problem
for the entire case let's just break
this down for a second so he gets
arrested back in the day for beating up
a guy for having his sex related
material by the way overseeing a case
about multiple women killed where
there's a sexual component possibly and
then he gets arrested again on sex
related charges it's it's quite the
headline but you heard Terry say how it
might affect Rex yourman's trial what's
your take on how effectively going to
affect it I might even go as far as
pointing the finger at him because he is
the original uh detective who gets to
pick who to question who to investigate
where to go as a defense attorney I'm
planting the seed of how do we know that
these are the sex workers we should be
talking to how do we know that these are
the leaves we should have been
investigating maybe he's pointing us
down the wrong path because we should be
looking at something else how do we know
that his involvement with sex workers
goes just at solicitation I think if the
defense can find something even good
enough maybe even point the finger to
him being the person that are killing
and bearing these bodies the only thing
a counter argument to that is he wasn't
in charge when Rexy Roman was arrested
from 2012 to 2015 he was a large part of
the investigation that probably I think
they used to lead up to it so it's like
a fruit of the poisonous tree argument
or anything else if the roots of the
tree are bad how can you use anything of
the fruit you agree yeah I do I actually
agree because I think even though he
wasn't in charge when huberman was
arrested all of that information that
they gathered while they were
investigating was something that Burke
had a piece of and he could have been
trying to direct it in the wrong
direction I definitely think it's a good
defense argument it's funny that Terry
says she actually agrees with you Brian
once in a while once in a blue moon all
right when we come back a 19 year old
finds out if she can attend college in
person after being charged with killing
her newborn baby and hiding his body in
a trash can it is the case of Alexi
Treviso that's next
[Music]
foreign
we're finishing Today's Show back in New
Mexico where a pre-trial hearing took
place for the 19 year old accused of
killing her newborn son in a hospital
bathroom and hiding his body in a trash
can now we first told you about the
hearing on Tuesday Alexi trevizo is
charged with first-degree murder child
abuse and tampering with evidence in
connection to the incident in late
January Treviso went to the hospital
with back pain allegedly not knowing she
was pregnant but 24 hours later hospital
staff found the body of treviso's son in
a bathroom trash can an autopsy ruled
the baby's death a homicide apparently
dying from a lack of oxygen but defense
attorneys argue that treviso's son was
in fact stillborn and the baby's death
was actually a result of Hospital
malpractice in Tuesday's hearing
multiple motions were addressed ahead of
treviso's October trial including
requests to change the conditions of a
pre-trial release so that she can attend
college in the fall Treviso is not
allowed to have contact with her
boyfriend who attends the same universe
University but the defense argues that
their relationship wasn't tumultuous
enough to restrict your visa from
attending classes in person so let's
hear what the judge ultimately decided
I'm going to go ahead and I'm going to
allow I'm going to modify the conditions
of release I'll allow her to go
it's New Mexico state and Las Cruces
right that's correct your honor it is
big university huge I don't know what
the student count is but I'm sure it's
several thousand
um Las Cruces is a sizable City
um our personally Council I I'm really
trying to get in my mind how you can
invoke a domestic violence
prohibition against personal contact
first off nobody's invoked the DV
statute there's been no allegation of
domestic violence I don't think that
translates into this I really don't my
my gut reaction is that's that does not
translate granted
you can order that anybody who's under
charges cannot commit any further
criminal Acts
and I'd certainly think that's
absolutely reasonable
she should get her conditions revoked if
she's gets charged with any further
criminal acts but I don't see how the DV
statutes can even be applied in this
case notwithstanding what judge Schubert
said originally or anything else
all right so Terry the judge modified
the conditions of that
um did she get it right there so you did
get it right and she's you know
surprised that the former judge put
conditions like that and I was also
surprised in fact I was you know
outraged I don't think that any judge
should say oh you cannot go to a
university first of all she's out she's
released and you can have conditions
that you don't commit another crime or
that you don't flee the jurisdiction but
to say that you can't go to this college
or you can't interact with your
boyfriend I think was far too
restrictive so the judge made the right
decision I will say however that the
defense attorney for Treviso said look
we'll make sure that she's got the right
advice the right counseling that she's
not going to get into a relationship
that she's not going to get pregnant
again I think that's wrong I think it
should be up to her up to her boyfriend
it is no one else's decision whether or
not she's going to get pregnant again
that's like saying okay I'm gonna get
pregnant again and I'm going to have you
know I'm gonna murder my baby they can't
just decide that for her so I'm still
upset that they're willing to put that
type of condition on her I'm happy that
they allowed her to go to college where
she wants to go and that they allowed
her to have interactions with her
boyfriend as long as they don't discuss
the case but I still think that it's a
bit Draconian to say yeah we're going to
make sure she is counseled and she
doesn't you know get pregnant so let me
ask you a different question Brian about
the suppression of the statements in
this case suppression of the statements
of Lexi Treviso I think the judge said
they need a little bit more information
before deciding on that how what would
sway the judge one way or another what
kind of evidence what kind of arguments
I think for the most part it comes down
to how those hippo rules of patients
clients uh privilege exists and also
Miranda warnings work I think for the
most part the strongest arguments the
prosecution house that the third party
was there but police can't just
interject them well they do but they
should not be allowed to just interject
themselves into areas where privilege
occurs and then say well no privilege
exists because I'm standing here
statements at the hospital correct yeah
and and I think with the judge you and
I'm seeing it from how she's talking
about what Terry just mentioned about
going back to the DB statue because you
actually are allowed to stop people from
going to The Homeschool place of
business uh or anywhere a person
typically goes when there's DV related
issues because DB statues allow that but
here the Old Judge pulled on the DV
statue and DB doesn't exist so this
tells me the judge is really trying to
make this case bulletproof from an
appellate issue standpoint and so
they're looking to see what exactly is
this going to hold or what's the
linchpin going to be to say this is why
the statement should come in or they
shouldn't because they're such a big
part of the case it's very eerily
similar to the Skyler Richardson case
which we covered here on Long crime
we'll see how this Ultima shakes out
Brian Terry thank you everyone thanks
for joining us we're going to see you
next time as we discuss Justice and
thank you